vou compartilhar com vocês uma lista dos
seis suplementos ou combinações deles
que eu acho super essenciais PR os
idosos terem excelente qualidade de vida
e mais longevidade Olá dr aland Dutra
aqui à medida que envelhecemos o corpo
passa por uma série de mudanças que
podem afetar de forma negativa a
absorção de nutrientes essenciais e
aumentar a necessidade de certos
suplementos essas mudanças podem levar a
deficiências nutricionais que TM o
potencial de IMPA tá de forma
significativa a saúde e a qualidade de
vida na terceira idade por isso vou
compartilhar com vocês uma lista do seis
suplementos que eu acho super essenciais
fundamentais para os idosos terem
excelente qualidade de vida e mais
longevidade número um aminoácidos
essenciais são fundamentais para saúde e
bem-estar desempenh um papel chave na
nutrição especialmente em dietas
restritivas ou entre populações
vulneráveis como os idosos os
aminoácidos essenciais são blocos
construtores de proteínas essenciais
para diversas funções biológicas incluem
síntese de proteínas regulação do
metabolismo manutenção da saúde muscular
e óssea eles são os blocos de construção
do nosso corpo com o envelhecimento a
eficiência na utilização de proteínas
pelo corpo diminui levando a perda
muscular natural e essa perda está
diretamente relacionado à desaceleração
metabólica então é importantíssimo repor
os aminoácidos a suplementação adequada
com esses aminoácidos essenciais pode
contrabalançar esses efeitos promovendo
uma melhor síntese proteica e
contribuindo para a manutenção da massa
muscular e do metabolismo ativo a
leucina é o aminoácido essencial ela
desempenha um papel crucial Ao tornar as
proteínas mais biodisponíveis estudos
indicam que a suplementação com leucina
pode quadruplicar a síntese proteica a
partir do consumo de proteínas
potencializando o aproveitamento de
nutrientes então a inclusão desse
aminoácido deve ser feita de forma
preferencial junto as refeições ricas em
proteínas como carnes ovos ou Fontes
vegetais para maximizar a absorção e
utilização pelo organismo contudo para
indivíduos com ingestão limitada de
proteínas recomenda-se a inclusão de um
shake proteico de alta qualidade para
garantir o aporte necessário de
aminoácidos que é vital em todas as
fases da vida e especialmente entre os
idosos que sofrem frequentemente com
sarcopenia que é os músculos fracos e
perda de massa muscular o segundo
suplemento é o ômega-3 é uma gordura
essencial uma vasta gama de benefícios
pra saúde incluindo saúde cardiovascular
propriedades antiinflamatória e suporte
a saúde cerebral ômega-3 é muito top e é
amplamente conhecido por seus benefícios
à saúde do coração ajudando a prevenir
doenças cardíacas atua na regulação dos
trigliceridos e na prevenção da formação
de placas arteriais contribuindo assim
paraa manutenção do sistema
cardiovascular saudável uma das
principais vantagens dos ácidos grassos
omega-3 é a sua capacidade de combater a
inflamação no corpo o que é benéfico
para reduzir os sintomas relacionados a
condições inflamatórias como
osteoartrite e outras doenças crônicas
pesquisa sugere que ômega-3 pode
desempenhar um papel crucial na
desaceleração do declínio cognitivo
Protegendo o cérebro contra doenças
degenerativas uma doença de alzheimer a
suplementação com ômega-3 então é
associado a melhoria na função cerebral
especialmente importante na terceira
idade então a suplementação com óleo de
peixe rico em ômega-3 óleo de crio óleo
de algas pode ser particularmente
benéfica na terceira idade ajudando a
mitigar o risco de doenças crônicas e
promovendo um envelhecimento saudável
então próximo item é a coenzima q10
junto com o pqq então falando primeiro
da coenzima q10 ou coq10
é um componente crucial envolvido na
produção de energia celular desempenha
um papel Vital em diversos processos
biológicos incluindo suporte à função
cardíaca controle do diabetes tipo 2
redução do risco de câncer e proteção
contra doenças neurodegenerativas como a
doença de alzheimer Então a partir do
envelhecimento a produção natural da
coenzima q10 pelo corpo diminui o que
pode contribuir para o desenvolvimento
de problemas de saúde relacionados à
idade por isso recomenda-se aumentar a
ingestão dessa coenzima seja através de
suplementos ou através de alimentação
como estratégia para promover um
envelhecimento saudável a pirinola
quinona mais conhecida como pqq afeta
positivamente a saúde de nível
metabólico em mitocôndrias as
mitocôndrias são presentes em grande
quantidade nos músculos são responsáveis
pela produção de energia nas células a
densidade mitocondrial tende a diminuir
com a idade afetando negativamente o
metabolismo de devido à redução da
capacidade energética muscular então o
pqq ele é conhecido por estimular a
biogênese mitocondrial Ou seja a
formação de novas mitocôndrias isso vai
levar a aumento da densidade
mitocondrial e é crucial para manter o
metabolismo ativo saudável especialmente
em idades avançadas que a perda das
mitocôndrias e da eficiência de produção
de energia mitocondrial e Estudos
publicados na revista bioquímica
nutricional indicam que o consumo de pqq
pode resultar em menoria significativas
na função mitocondrial E além disso
observou-se uma redução nos marcadores
inflamatórios como Inter leucina 6 e
proteína C reativa que são importantes
indicadores de inflamação e saúde geral
especialmente em dosos a combinação de
com enzima que 10 e pqq pode ser uma
excelente dupla para oferecer suporte
paraa saúde energética e metabólica
especialmente benéfica para pessoas
acima de 40 ou 50 anos de idade quarto
item eletrólito são minerais essenciais
que desempenham papéis cruciais no corpo
humano incluindo o transporte de água
para células a condução de impulsos
elétricos necessários para movimentos
musculares a função de órgãos vitais e a
manutenção da hidratação adequada Então
os eletrólitos mais conhecidos são sódio
potássio magnésio cálcio e cloreto com o
envelhecimento ocorrem mudanças
fisiológicas que afetam o equilíbrio dos
eletrólitos processo conhecido como
senescência essas alterações podem
comprometer a capacidade dos zins de
filtrar a adequadamente manter os níveis
desses minerais eletrólitos tornando os
idosos particularmente vulneráveis a
desequilíbrios eletrolíticos
medicamentos e condições predisponentes
podem agir como agentes estressores
alterando os níveis desses minerais de
sódio e outros eletrólitos uma dieta
balanceada rica em Fontes naturais de
eletrólitos é fundamental para manter o
equilíbrio desses minerais essenciais
então o magnésio emular ele é muito
importante ele pode ser exigido a
reposição contínua na dieta dos idosos
Já que é muito comum a sua deficiência
além de ter benefícios extras com a sua
suplementação já que ele pode ajudar o
corpo a produzir proteínas e ossos
manter o açúcar do sangue estável ajuda
a equilibrar a pressão arterial melhora
o sono e câimbras musculares Além disso
ele pode contribuir na melhora da
constipação intestinal que é bem comum
na terceira idade suplementos
específicos de eletrólitos também podem
ser uma opção para garantir níveis
adequados especialmente em casos de
restrição dietética ou necessidades
aumentadas o quito inem é a vitamina D
ou hormônio D conhecido como a vitamina
do sol é um nutriente essencial solúvel
em gordura que é sintetizado pela pele
quando você é exposto à luz solar então
é fundamental para várias funções
corporais incluindo absorção de cálcio
saúde óssea função muscular suporte de
defesa né suporte imunológico a vitamina
D encontrada naturalmente em poucos
alimentos tornando a exposição solar uma
fonte primária para a maioria das
pessoas adultos mais velhos tem um risco
aumentado de deficiência de vitamina D
devido a vários fatores incluindo menor
exposição ao sol para reduzir o risco de
câncer de pele e a tendência de passar
mais tempo em ambientes fechados então a
capacidade da pele de sintetizar
vitamina D também diminui com a idade
então a vitamina D desempenha um papel
crucial na regulação da absorção de
cálcio essencial paraa manutenção da
saúde ósea e prevenção de doenças como
osteoporose então é muito importante se
preocupar com a vitamina D e ter um ção
solar adequada então estudos indicam que
a suplementação com a vitamina D pode
contribuir para o aumento da massa
muscular o que é particularmente
benéfico para idosos ajudando a prevenir
quedas e melhorar a mobilidade então a
vitamina D conhecida por suas
propriedades de fortalecimento do
sistema imune de defesa Além disso pode
desempenhar um papel na diminuição dos
sintomas de depressão especialmente
indivíduos com níveis insuficientes
muito baixos de vitamina D que é muito
comum hoje em dia o sexto item vitaminas
do complexo B temos que dar ênfase na
B12 que é a que mais tem deficiência e
as vitaminas do complexo B são
essenciais para várias funções vitais no
corpo humano incluindo a produção de
energia reparo do DNA saúde do sistema
imune e função cerebral a deficiência do
Complexo B pode levar a sérios problemas
de saúde como declínio cognitivo
osteoporose doenças cardíacas
especialmente adultos mais velhos à
medida que as pessoas vão envelhecendo a
produção de ácido no estômago diminui
isso afeta de forma negativa a
capacidade do corpo de absorver
vitaminas do complexo B especialmente a
B6 e a B12 e certas medicações de uso
contínuo da terceira idade muito comuns
também podem ter Impacto isso pode
contribuir pro risco aumentado de
deficiência dessas vitaminas então a
deficiência dessa vitamina do Complexo B
A B12 é preocupante pois está associada
a várias complicações de saúde estima-se
que a deficiência de B12 afeta cerca de
40% das pessoas com mais de 60 anos de
idade é possível que pelo menos alguns
dos sintomas atribuídos ao
envelhecimento normal como perda de
memória declínio cognitivo diminuição da
mobilidade sejam pelo menos em parte
causados pela deficiência de B12 é
crucial para adultos com mais de 50 anos
discutir com profissional de saúde a
possibilidade suplementar ab12 além de
monitorar regularmente os níveis dessa
vitamina para prevenir deficiências e
suas complicações associadas Fica de
olho nisso que é muito comum
especialmente em idosos compartilhe os
vídeos fao bem a vida de alguém pode
mudar também no canal do
al um grande abraço um beijo no seu
coração e conforme fala a musiquinha não
deixe Compartilhar esse vídeo com seus
amigos e familiares você é fera por ter
compartilhado